on ground that is sacred to both jews
and muslims
guns and tear gas days of tension in the
muslim holy month of ramadan
and a right-wing israeli march planned
through occupied east jerusalem
made for a combustible mix but it was
the imminent eviction of scores of
palestinians
to make way for jewish settlers that
sparked this latest explosion
in the middle of jerusalem's old city
the radioactive heart of the middle east
peace process
for jews the temple mount their most
holy site muslims call it haram
al-sharif their third most holy place
palestinians say it's threatened by land
grabs by jewish settlers
for the first time whole communities of
palestinians face eviction
hundreds of people in sheikh jarrah in
the north the site of recent tensions
and baton al hawa to the south
palestinians fear the occupied old city
will end up completely surrounded by
jewish settlements
and they're taking a stand israel
occupied east jerusalem and its old city
in the six
day war in 1967 but israelis and
palestinians both wanted as their
capitals
in any future peace deal for many years
international law has been very clear
east jerusalem is under israel's
military occupation
that occupation has to be temporary that
occupation is governed
by very clear rules israel is in breach
of all
these rules israel commits war crimes on
a regular basis
there are other factors palestinian
unease about gulf states making peace
with israel with little mention of their
cause
and israeli politics moving to the right
as benjamin netanyahu fights for his
political life
and against corruption charges israelis
reject criticism that their handling of
the situation
has been excessive we as a government
cannot allow
this sort of orchestrated violence to
dictate the reality and we will do
what needs to be done to preserve peace
and quiet
this may have begun with a threat of
more evictions but it's escalated
dramatically
what happens in jerusalem doesn't always
stay in jerusalem
rocket fire from gaza has already proven
that and things may well
worsen still dominic waghorn sky news